GOOD HOCKEY TEAM BOUGHT INTO
DEFENSE-FIRST SYSTEM
ADIN HILL LOOKED LIKE HE HAD
THAT SOMEHOW BEAT HIM ON THE
GLOVE-HAND SIDE AND WASHINGTONO
AND FINDS THE FIVE-HOLE ON ADIN
HILL
SHIMERGAME, ONLY CALGARY HAS DOT
MORE
GOODR.
NOW HATHAWAY GETTING INTO IT
WITH BARABANOV AND THEY'RED ON
>> Randy: DMITRY ORLOV, ONE OF
THE CORE, LEFT OVER FROMTURNINGT
DANIEL SPRONG.
FORMER ANAHEIM DUCK.
>> Randy: ORLOV, HEADS TO THE
BENCH.
CAPITALS CHANGE ON THE OF THE N
AND SETTLED BYFJALLBY.T THE SHAD
IT'S A 1-0 WIDE.
BALCERS.
BONINO
ABLE TO SLOW I, FIRST GAME
BACK IN TEN AND SMOKES WAITING
COMING.
>> Randy: NIETO.
SPEED THROUGH THE HE CAN AVERAG
YEAR HE'LL CATCH THE GREAT ONEOH
GREGOR
CORALS IT.
FO
YOS JOB IS TO SHOOT THEE IT UP,F
IT
ADIN HILL TO THE FAR POST.
>> Randy: FOR IT.
>> Randy: JUSTIN SCHULTZ SENDS
IT T AND
COULDN'T GET ENOUGH OF THIS  I
SHOT
AS IT WAS TI
MEIER.>> Bret: YEAH.
>> Randy: THIS TIME DAHLEN'S
BACK, TH PUCK IN THE
OFFENSIVE BLOWS.
TOMAMAT IS
>> Randy: NOAH GREGOR IS IN THE
PENALTY  THEY'RE ON THEIR
HEELS.
>> Randy: VAN RIEMSDYK
FOR WILSON
BACK FOR SCHULTZ BOTHER HIM.CALL
THOUGH FOR TOMAS HERTL TO TAKE
THAT CROSS CHECK.
>> Randy: SHARKS HAVE G ME
3-0. IN THE GLOVE!
>> Bret: HITS HIM IN THE STICK T
ALEX OVECHKINLOCK THIS ONE
COMING IN.